how are most americans feeling about the
future and why are currently employed
americans particularly gen z and
millennials looking for different jobs
this year we track down the answers
there are definite signs americans are
feeling a bit more hopeful about 2022
according to fidelity investment's
latest study more than six in 10
americans feel optimistic about the
future despite the unknown the
prevailing sentiment for 2022 is
cautious optimism and that feeling is
even stronger among women and the
younger generations stacy watson senior
vp of life events planning at fidelity
says 72 percent are confident they'll be
in a better financial position this year
people have become better at setting
goals and attaining them and that's
creating hope but despite the optimism
most people have not forgotten what the
country has been through and are viewing
their financial expectations practically
with concerns about inflation and rising
costs the financial actions people took
at the start of the pandemic out of
necessity like budgeting and building
back emergency savings have become
permanent habits now by choice we will
continue to hear about the great
resignation throughout the year
particularly among the younger
generations according to fidelity's
research half of gen z millennials
currently employed say they are looking
to change jobs this year and here's why
aside from money the reasons for
changing jobs are all values based with
stress levels flexibility
better alignment with personal values
all listed as top motivations
she adds before making any career move
really think through the reason for
leaving your job and talk to your
current manager about what you really
want to get out of it and if they can't
fulfill it look elsewhere